Okay, so I want to do, VIP tickets sold first.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so. Let's see what's going on
here. We've got our master object festival, and it's
summarizing something. okay. Not much there, summarizing attendees. Oh,
because it's the only thing that it's related to.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. And roll-up type. Count. I'm guessing that would tell me that
there were two.
>> That would count the number of records.
>> Okay, which is not what we want to do.
>> Right.
>> We want to add up the number of tickets sold.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. This is actually making
sense. Field to Aggregate. Tickets Purchased? Yes.
>> Yes.
>> But only if they're VIP tickets.
>> So what's great is at the very bottom
you can see there you can create a filter criteria.
>> Okay. all records should, no, only records meeting certain criteria.
Oh, this is easy. Field is Ticket Type.
>> Exactly.
>> What's operator? Oh, okay, equals.
And equals VIP, yeah?
>> Yep.
>> Sweet.
>> And you can do a lot of different kind of calculations, as you can
see. So, the minimum value, the maximum value,
some sort of aggregate, and you can get
it to be pretty complicated with your
filters. Well that's great. So now you have
a count of your VIP tickets, but you
probably want one for general admission to right?
>> Wait, first I want to see, I want to see if this actually worked.
I'm want to go to Cloudstock an see if I can, actually see this thing.
Hey, it's pretty cool. Okay. Alright now, I will
do the same thing for the general admission tickets.
>> Right